robotic process automation
is the use of software with artificial
intelligence
and machine learning capabilities to
handle high volume
repeated tasks that were previously
required humans to perform
a very warm welcome to all our viewers
and in this video
we will be looking at the top 10 rpa
projects
many businesses are looking rpa as a
solution to help them
enhance efficiencies and cut cost rps is
businesses across a wide range of
industries
in completing a variety of activities
there are plenty of excellent rpa
projects available
we will discuss the 10 most exciting
real-time rpa projects in this video
let's look at today's agenda the 10
projects
which we will be looking at in this
video are as follows
number one we will look at web scraping
crm upgrading support sales and
marketing
data generation call center operations
onboarding of employees payroll
processing
claims processing legal processing
and lastly data wiring for a healthcare
system
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos
then subscribe to our youtube channel
and make sure you hit the bell icon to
never miss an update
the first project is web scraping
it is also known as screen scraping web
harvesting
web automation and web data extraction
because of its function
scraping is a method of extracting huge
amount of data from a website and saving
it to a local file or a database
businesses frequently search for
relevant information on a competitor's
or a specific website
however the data on the most websites
can only be read
there is no way to copy it for personal
use
as a result a time consuming action of
copying and pasting data is required
in a fraction of the time this can be
accomplished with robotic
process automation the web scraping
software
is programmed to load and extract the
relevant data automatically
as a result you will save energy and
money
web scraping is used by a variety of
businesses from e-commerce stores to
stock dealers to obtain data
manual web scraping on the other hand
might be very costly
this is why business automate the
process
you can check out our video on uipath
web automation
where we have explained web automation
in detail
along with a demo
the next project is crm upgrading
customer relationship management is a
set of techniques
methods and technologies for managing
customer interactions and data
crm is used to increase customer
interactions
loyalty and sales across the customer
life cycle
employees in this field typically have
basic
repetitive and rule-based work with
moderate or high volumes
making this a good choice for rpa where
a bot replaces human effort rpa systems
are designed to handle tasks like this
rpa can perform repetitive rule based
and high volume activities with ease
crm systems collect data about clients
from many channels
and points of interaction the example of
these channels are
company's website phone live chat
mail and social media rpa systems
are already in use and completely
functional
they can accomplish any repetitive task
that a human
undertakes in a smarter way using
cognitive technologies
due to significant costs and operations
management benefits provided by
rpa a significant shift in business
process
is projected to occur very soon
the next project is support sales and
marketing
sales and marketing departments are
among the most
revenue generating areas in many
businesses
you want to free up your sales team to
do what they do the best
that is sell in order to create leads
and drive growth
businesses large or small are
discovering that removing the hurdles
that prevent sales and marketing workers
from executing their critical can help
them maximize their time
rpa automates tasks on behalf of
employees
by combining software robots with
business rules
it is well known that the interface of
marketing and sales
is frequently used to attract new
customers
while marketing has advanced
significantly in terms of automation
sales productivity still relies heavily
on human involvement
nonetheless there are variety of sales
related sub functions that can be
automated
a few of them are as follows
sales strategy and long term planning
forecasting labor planning resource
allocation
and channel strategy are all things that
need to be considered lead
identification and qualification
pipeline management as well as planning
for new and existing clients
pricing and quotations setting bits
coming up with technological solutions
negotiating and contracting are all the
things that are done in pricing and
quotation
management of orders credit checks
invoicing
and order processing are all things that
need to be done
management of after sales services
monitoring
follow-up and management of post-sale
request on a regular basis
assistive function reporting analysis
training administration and the
development of sales materials
data generation or data migration
the process of moving data from one
location to another
from one format to another or from one
application to another
is known as data migration this is
usually the outcome of introducing a new
data system
or location one-time activities like
data migration
and test data generation are frequently
overlooked
despite the fact that rps ability to
seamlessly connect systems
without the need for time and cost
intensive programming of interfaces
and standalone applications may be
particularly useful for these purposes
one of the most difficult aspects of
data transfer
is the range of source systems and as a
result the variety of data formats
to tackle this problem complex mapping
tables
intermediate formats and data cleansing
are routinely used
these tasks not only increase migration
expenses
but they also quickly escalate to point
where the complexity appears
unmanageable
rpa which automates typical process
provides a simple
cost effective and effective solution to
all of these issues
high adaptability at lower cost rpa is
used to work with an almost limitless
number of systems
interfaces and data types this feature
is built in all rps software systems and
is available out of the box
any client specific customizing can be
done quickly and easily
high quality data because rpa uses
existing guis
rather than bespoke interfaces any
discrepancies or data quality issues are
quickly detected by the underlying
systems
as a result before your migration data
is delivered to the destination systems
it can be scanned and corrected needless
to mention
rpa can also be used to generate any
quality of test data
needed to improve the quality of the
routines
documentation rps software flexibility
allows it to create practically any log
file required in a given situation
rpa may generate log files at any degree
of detail
and in any file type like text word
excel pdf etc and then propagate the
results as needed
call center operation
when a customer contacts an agent the
agent must first identify them in the
system
in order to obtain relevant data such as
order status
order number order location pending
tickets
and shipment id this requires the agent
interacting with the customer
while simultaneously moving from one
system to another
the database which contains the
customer's information
and the other system which contains
additional information
customers must wait while the
representative is busy dealing with the
data
sometimes asking for the information
that has already been requested
this tends to decrease customer
satisfaction and extends call duration
rpa takes a user-friendly approach to
data integration
and process management the need to
switch between direct applications
is eliminated by loading a full customer
profile from numerous systems
by automating actions such as
application launch
mouse clicks field entries and so on
when rpa is used in call centers it
drastically decreases the time
it takes to locate a customer in the
system and examine all information about
them on a single screen
as a result the customer does not have
to wait for the agent
to load all the information resulting in
improved customer service and shorter
average call length onboarding of
employees
hr is one of the departments that is
actively considering introducing
rpa into its working procedures with
particular focus
on onboarding process
the onboarding process prepares new
employees for the new workplace
by providing them with essential
knowledge skills
and behavior this process usually begins
before the first day of work
and is an important aspect of
integrating a newly
hired employee into the organization's
payroll and internal databases
employee onboarding sets the tone for a
new employee's career
with your firm and is crucial in
preparing them to contribute
meaningfully
yet for the most part onboarding new
staff is still a tedious and wasteful
procedure
rpa improves hr procedures that are
still run on older system
such as onboarding by adding new
functionality
decreasing human error and securing data
the organization was able to cut the
process time to 3-4 minutes per new
employee
using a combination of rpa robots the
greater accuracy of the automation
also reduced the time required for
examining and rectifying problems
previously
during high volume hiring periods the
system proved to be easily extendable
and the organization was able to
optimize data input
resource allocation and error handling
by monitoring the automated process
the tasks performed by rpf bots in
onboarding process
are cleaning resumes in process of new
hire
verify candidates information induction
and training
employment management and send
notifications to the new employees
payroll processing
payroll processing is a critical company
operation that
involves calculating employees net pay
after deducting
applicable taxes and deductions
payroll processing is one of the most
important but also one of the most time
consuming
operations in any company due to the
importance of
accuracy in order to avoid stiff irs
penalties
manually updating payroll system is
difficult and potentially costly
because of high level of risk and the
time consuming nature of manually
updating records
businesses have begun to turn to
automation to reduce mistakes and time
wasted
consider a scenario where in every month
an hr service provider manually
processed 100 000 payroll
change occurrences it took around 60
hours and 6 full time personals
to complete the process the operation
was inefficient
and complex because it comprised
numerous departments
and two essential desktop apps
all payroll updates received through
email from customers
are now handled by an rpa robot
which automatically inputs them into a
sap system
in approximately few weeks the rpa
solution was up and running
automating 90 percent of previous labor
necessary to process this request
claims processing
claims processing is at the core of
insurance industry
the insurance company satisfies its
commitment to its consumers
establishes service standards builds
credibility
and performs its commitments at this
stage many
insurers have already implemented some
kind of automation
whether it's simple task like scanning
pdf documents
or more extensive workflow automation
these solutions on the other hand
are different and each have their own
set of issues
actually they can further add to the
complexity and difficulty of processing
the quality of the output from this
automation is mostly determined by the
programming quality
every time a step in the process is
altered the enter software must be
written
this complicates the claims process
exposes it to errors
and adds to the expenses this is where
robotic process automation
enters the picture as fully integrated
end-to-end automation solution
that overcomes the existing issues rpa
operates at presentation layer
seamlessly interacting with all
applications and systems
including the older system it is
completely scalable
to meet the needs of the user and offers
robotic accuracy of up to 100
legal processing
in terms of legal and compliance
processes
this means that your lawyers and
specialists will be able to respond
more swiftly to the rising client and
internal stakeholder demands
in-house legal departments and
independent law firms
both can benefit from ui path robotic
process automation solutions for legal
this frees up all your highly qualified
legal professionals
to focus on what matters most learning
the law
and providing best legal advice possible
to your clients
rpa automates operations on top of
existing systems
such as legal documents apps
spreadsheets pdfs and websites
in simple editor you can quickly design
robots
even lawyers and barristers have the
ability to develop their own automation
the last project is data wiring for a
healthcare system
healthcare providers strive to provide
high quality care to as many people as
possible
however both providers and payers must
complete and handle a plenty of forms
documentation and data in order to do so
all of these data like patient records
provider information
billing and payment information is
collected
processed filed and stored in a mess of
segregated and separate systems
healthcare has become confusing and
sluggish due to a plethora of process
and networks
resulting in care that is potentially
more expensive
slower and ineffective for patients this
also means
lower profitability for private
suppliers
robotic process automation is a tool
that aids in the digital transformation
process
in a nutshell it's the wiring that
connects all of the data
in all of the systems in a way that's
faster more accurate
and more efficient than traditional iit
approaches like
complex business process management
system custom application program
interfaces
and other rpa when combined with
artificial intelligence
can swiftly and accurately push and draw
a large amount of data
from one system to another in addition
to speeding up the system
it frees up humans to undertake more
value-added work
by removing time time-consuming
low-value jobs from their hands
so with that we have reached the end of
this video i hope you liked this video
if you have any doubts ask in the
comment section our professionals will
try to answer all your questions
please like share and subscribe if you
found it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to sinclair
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here